hey what's up y'all it's almost
halloween which means one thing and one
thing only it's candy time
that's right
[Music]
even though some people think it's
controversial um i love candy corn
i don't care what you think you don't
have to eat it i will fine
and over the years they've really
stepped up their game candy corn and
with new
wild and exciting flavors so today i
have a bunch of unusual candy corn
concoctions in front of me
and i have to guess what flavor it is so
there better not be like some weird
harry potter booger one or something
all right let's do this
[Music]
here we go does it matter where i start
i'm starting here
looks good
[Music]
no i say no
that was too um okay i actually like
cherry coke but
um as cherry coke like not like this
um that wasn't my favorite
[Music]
okay
oh my god oh my god
it was like meat i don't know it's like
meat
is it meat oh my god that is
gnarly this is like a trick because you
just send this to someone you don't like
i have a list
[Music]
um
i'm okay with that one oh caramel apple
i just saw in the camera they peeked
they showed me i didn't know that
caramel apple's good you should go for
caramel apple
nicely done i say
[Music]
absolutely not absolutely not
oh my god i have to slow the rest no
don't
[Music]
it's so gross i don't know what that one
was it's so gross
oh my god sweet potato pie which once
again love sweet potato pie
not as candy corn nope
oh i'm scared it's gonna be like grass
or something
no no
[Music]
oh my god it's gross it's like a
vegetable
yeah it's green beans that's just rude
rude
here we go
i'm not offended by that i don't know
what that is
i have no idea what that is oh cranberry
sauce you know go for that one that was
a good one
nice
[Music]
[Applause]
oh i hope this is like root see it looks
like it would be like root beer float or
something
no no i don't like that one
that was weird it's grainy i don't know
it was
i don't know what the oh my god once
again i love s'mores you know what
it doesn't have to be everywhere it can
just be its own special thing like
cherry cola and sweet potato pie
[Music]
oh is this the regular that's my
favorite no
oh my god oh my god
is there like butterscotch on that oh
it's pumpkin pie
once again i love pumpkin pie you know
what just don't you don't have to do it
you don't have to rent it
like i'm just saying
[Music]
okay
that flavor like hit later you know
i don't know what it is but it hit later
i don't know what that is but i'm not
into it oh apple pie i mean it was kind
of nice and then you were like no
i was on the fence
oh my god oh my god
y'all are rude that was so nasty
what the hell was that oh my god
stuffing gnarly
that was disgusting
[Music]
oh my god i'm afraid
[Music]
nope nope
oh my god i don't even know what just
happened it was like citrusy
oh it was carrots what what the hell is
wrong with you no
i don't want carrot if i wanted a carrot
i'd eat a damn carrot
[Music]
all right well i would have to say
my favorites obviously not um
oh caramel apple is probably my favorite
and
i like cranberry sauce those were
probably my two favorites
the others i'm fine those were probably
my
favorites the caramel apples real good
thank you so much to brox and dylan's
candy bar for making these candy corn
concoctions
i will never think of candy corn the
same way again
looking at you turkey see you soon
[Music]